the Trump administration may increase
the number of United States troops in
Afghanistan this week defense secretary
James Madison is granted authority to
set those levels retired four-star
General Stanley McChrystal commanded
American and international forces in
Afghanistan he also served as commander
of the Joint Special Operations Command
McChrystal was tasked with reimagining
the battlefields of the Middle East the
outlined how he did that in his 2015
bestseller team of team new rules of
engagement for a complex world one of
his co-authors would form a Navy SEAL
Chris bustle
Russell has now Pollard that up with a
book of his own the book is called one
mission how leaders build a team of
teams the book shows how people in any
field can apply general McChrystal's
lesson to their organization good
morning to both of you Laura
There is obviously concern around the
nation we're going to see the baseball
game this evening and we saw this
tragedy happen yesterday in a sense of
because you think about national
security you think about this country
and you think about the timely
conversation what was your reaction when
you watch that yesterday and what we
need to be thinking about well I think
like everybody else it's horror at what
happened but it's also the hope that it
starts a national conversation about a
number of issues one is partisanship one
is about conversation itself and another
is about why so many people are being
killed by guns in our country and I
think we need thoughtful people to come
together and take on a tough issue you
know Chris that's what struck me
yesterday you know we've been reporting
on it all morning 5,200 shots but when
you actually hear the gunshots and you
hear how long that it took and what
those people must have been going to you
know as a Navy SEAL you know the sound
what were you thinking when you were
looking at that and what it all means
well obviously sympathy for the folks
are there in the poorest families and
and the the broader problem here which I
think Stan just identified that this is
this is increasing and that we have to
get our hands around this this issue and
for people that haven't been exposed to
that before I mean that's that's a
life-changing moment they'll wrestle
with for years sort of leadership that
we need in situations like this and what
sort of lessons do you think general can
be taken from the book well I think the
first is it's not all about a single
leader it's about a community of P
they come together because when we are
together we get more brains involved we
get more wisdom involved we get
different perspectives and we can make
decisions that actually have some kind
of consensus and support so if we always
look for a single iconic person I think
we make a mistake you right Chris about
the leadership myth hmm what does that
mean like you're [ __ ] man well it's in
our nature we have this tendency to want
to look for one person that will lead us
through tough times we saw that in the
military with our senior generals maybe
they'd say well we got the right general
in place but you always hear in business
you can only have one leader well you
have one leader but what great leaders
have always done and what they is more
important now than ever that they do is
they really bring teams together so they
create environment where we could
connect that was what was critical for
us in the military and I think that's
what's important now in industry and
politics you see it all over the
leadership is leadership is leadership I
mean whether it's in the military
whether it's in business whether it's in
politics that's right that's right what
are the core principles of that kind of
leadership well in today's world I think
it's more important than ever that
leaders create an environment where
those that are closest to these very
difficult problems in the world is being
driven by networked individuals and
interconnected problems leaders have to
empower those that are closest to those
issues to be able to move with autonomy
that's what worked for us in the service
and that's what we see working well in
industry as folks start to apply that
sort of model what did you take from
what you learned on the battlefield how
that can be translated into businesses
because most of us don't have your
skills or your skills general we're not
Navy SEALs and we're not equipped to
know to do the things that you do but
you said there are things that you do on
the battlefield that really can
translate into business I've been out of
the service for five years now and I've
been constantly impressed by the
similarities between the service and
industry there's great leaders there's
great people in those organizations that
want to do great things I just want to
be part of something that has deeper
meaning and that they feel attached to
and that's what was critical for us in
transitioning how special operations
worked and I think there's a lot of
similar characters in industry Chris
gentlemen Chris I'm Admiral McRaven was
here recently he's got a book he's
talking about which is about lessons
he's learned about starting with making
your bed but one of the interesting
things he talked about in terms
of Navy SEALs was that you often
surprised by those who make the cut
were you surprised it really is
interesting you'll have a someone that
just finished an Ironman Triathlon who
doesn't make it through the second week
of training and you know a 19 year old
kid from Iowa was never seen the ocean
who ends up being the top graduate so
it's really about inner character rather
than physical skill which is also about
leadership absolutely but what did you
see in him general because I loved how
you described him is one of your
favorite words charlie intellectually
curious that there was something about
him that stood out to you out of all the
people that you worked with when I was
first commanding and he was an
Operations Officer one of the
subordinate task force's Chris was
asking different questions he was asking
big questions he was asking how the
pieces fit together not about the focus
narrow things and that of course makes
an immediate impression one question
about the Secretary of Defense mattis
the president seemed to have given him
lots of authority is that a good thing
or do we mean be do we need to be
reminded you know that the heart of the
American system is civilian control I
think it is a good in order to empower
subordinates who are closest to the
problem to make decisions but you don't
abrogate responsibility so the president
of United States still has
responsibility for those decisions and
the American people ultimately still
have ownership of those decisions so it
has to be a melded system in which
civilians and military leaders together
arrive at right decisions but also
prosecute policies that everybody
supports that everyone understands
ultimately they may not agree going in
but when the policy is set we all have
the resolve to follow through general
the war in Afghanistan has been going on
since 2001 where should troop levels be
it's hard to say I certainly would defer
to what Jim mattis and McNichol son on
the ground are recommending but the
question I think we need to ask
ourselves is if we send more troops and
that doesn't solve the problem or make
that the change we hope what will we do
then and that's a question that the
nation needs to ask itself about its
long-term aims and objectives in
Afghanistan and what we're willing to
devote to achieve them alright thank you
so much great to see you good to see the
two of you think Ilana thank you and of
course is Stan Lee
Christel the general and Chris Russell
the name of the book is one mission it's
on sale now wherever you like to buy
your books